it is more than four years
since michelle barnier first started
negotiating a brexit deal with the uk
today he came to the european parliament
aware that time is running out
and that fishing remains a huge bone of
contention
the uk wants to find its sovereignty
regarding fishing
to be able to control access to its
waters
as i say often and i repeat to you all
we will accept
and respect that we are at the moment of
truth
with not much time left just a few hours
to be used in these negotiations
if we want this agreement to come into
effect from the first of january
there are other issues to resolve but
fishing is the most tangible
across brussels this fishmonger shop
buys most of its produce from french
boats
here they worry about europe's fleet
being excluded from british waters
the problem security the problem is that
in the channel in those waters there's
no wall
maybe i'm naive but i hope that that
doesn't happen
there has to be a free exchange within
the agreements that are reached
otherwise it's a big step back
talks continues today with little sign
of a breakthrough the optimism of
earlier this week has waned fishing has
huge symbolic weight in these
negotiations and boris johnson
said he would not sign up to an
agreement that did not allow the uk
control over its own waters and remember
the impact of deal or no deal will be
felt almost immediately by fishermen
on both sides of the channel in the
summer we went out with lohan molang
who's based in berlin but fishes in
british waters
today we spoke again as he waits
anxiously for a deal
fearful about his livelihood
cost we just won't accept it for now we
haven't said much because i think we
still had hope
but if we end up with a no deal then
we'll all take action
it will be a catastrophe for french
fishermen and for those of us with
smaller fishing boats our business will
be killed off
i absolutely believe that of the 30
boats operating here
in two years there will only be 10 left
that's for sure
fishing is hard work it is unpredictable
and tough
and it has a political resonance for
leaders on both sides of the channel
if there is to be a brexit deal there
will have to be a compromise
adam parsons sky news brussels